mindannyian úton vagyunk és valamerre
tartunk felkelünk nekivágunk a világnak
harcolunk majd este fáradtan
hazaérkezünk és kezdjük elölről közben
szeretnénk egészségesen élni tanulni
több időt tölteni a szeretteinkkel és
egy értelmes életet élni hogy megérje
reggel újra felkelni és küzdeni a
világunk egyre csak gyorsul és úgy
érezzük hogy semmire sincs időnk a
híreken sem tudunk eligazodni ellenmondó
információk jönnek velünk szembe nap
mint nap minden olyan kaotikus mit tetek
ha minden egészségtelen mit tanuljak ha
a mesterséges intelligencia úgyis átvesz
mindent mikor alapítsak családot
egyáltalán érdemes gyereket vállalni
erre a világra létezik igazság vagy
minden csak nézőpont kérdése ha pedig
nincs akkor miért ne éljek csak magamnak
és szórakozzak ameddig csak lehet van
egyáltalán helyes út vagy
elakadtunk tervezz újra mert vannak
alapelvek amibe kapaszkodhatunk tarts
velünk a navigátor podcastbe ahol a
vendégeimmel együtt ezeket k
[Zene]